this is Startalk so randall Zeisler
wants to know this he says hi bill with
Zika virus having been around for over
60 years we only hear about it when it
spreads to pandemic proportions how many
other viruses are out there that are
just contained to a certain area that
are waiting to spread under the right
conditions also what do you think will
be the next Zika virus well here's a
rosy outlook for you to paint Laurie
yeah precise question is what I have
focused on for the last you know three
decades professionally and we don't know
a number we can't give you an exact
count and say this is how many viruses
lurk out there one of the reasons is
that they're all mutating all the time
they adapt at an incredible pace at
whatever we throw at them including
climate change they reproduce so fast so
fast many of the viruses are reproducing
in the order of minutes or hours and of
course the bacteria are producing on the
order of days and humans are reproduce
in the order of years kids and so it
allows them tremendous advantage to
change and in a way you can look at any
given ecology whether it's right here at
the top the surface of this seems to be
some kind of felt here Bay's there is
there is a biome right right on this
surface we don't see it but there are a
lot of organisms living here and they
are the way people they're delicious and
they and they range from the big ones
you know parasites all the way down to
the really tiny ones phage which are
just little packets of DNA right that
attack viruses attack viruses and
bacteria and so here's what's happening
it's a giant lending library mm-hmm you
know all over here is DNA and bacteria
if I if they feel attacked if I had
antibiotics to splash it would feel more
fuzzy a little bit but if bacteria
experience an assault some sort of a
antiseptic I put on this surface
they scour actively their environment
for any phage that might have some DNA
that they can use to counter that's a
model for us Wow we scour the rainforest
and our tummies and everything else
looking for something that will fight
this a given we mostly destroy oh that's
great so by that I mean it's not great
so had caused the cold there gotta be
six here's the great guy I was in that
we've never heard the great guy up at
Columbia University at the Medical
School named Ian Lipkin who has proposed
a project to actually go out and scour
the planet for missing viruses and to
identify them is this into what craig
Venter was doing with his sailboat he
was doing total microbiome not just
viruses and he was just the Sargasso Sea
but now the NIH our National Institutes
of Health is looking at funding together
with NSF what they would call the earth
microbiome project to actively go out
and scour all kinds of different
ecological settings looking to identify
all of the bacteria viruses and phage in
a given community setting now that poses
another problem that I'm actually
working on in a new book I'm writing
which is when is a life-form a pathogen
and when is it an innocent bystander
orange or something happily helping you
sin beot a commensal something that
actually is digesting your food for you
or protecting you by doing combat with
other microbes right but then suddenly
they will switch and there'll be a
pathogen and we don't know why we don't
completely understand how this happens
it turns out almost every human being
has anthrax in your gut this is a huge
surprise we only discovered this in the
last couple of years well why is anthrax
in your gut harmless but anthrax in the
air or on a surface and as we all
learned in 2001 with the mailings to
members of Congress and the media why is
that a lethal event we don't really
understand but in any ecologic 'el
setting a plant and
animal the ocean the air there's this
mix of microbes which under certain
circumstances are at least neutral if
not beneficial and in other
circumstances are dangerous and we don't
really understand it this is Startalk